so before we talk about
sort of explore the different ideas
underlying interactive artificial
intelligence which we are working on let
me just go along this thread
to skip to kind of our world of social
media which is something that
at least on the artificial intelligence
side you think about
there's a popular narrative i don't know
if it's true
but that we have these silos
in social media and we have these
clusterings as you're kind of mentioning
and the idea is that you know along that
narrative
is that you know we want to we want to
break each other out
of those silos so we can be empathetic
to other
people to if you're a democrat you be
empathetic to the republican if you're a
republican you're a pathetic
democrat those are just two silly bins
that we seem to be very uh
excited about but there's other binnings
that we can think about
is there from an artificial intelligence
perspective
because you're just saying we cluster
along the data but then interactive
artificial intelligence
is is referring to throwing agents into
that mix ai systems in that mix
helping us interacting with us humans
and maybe getting us out of those silos
is that something that you think is
possible do you see
a hopeful possibility for artificial
intelligence systems
in these large networks of people
to get us outside of our habits in at
least the idea space
to where we can sort of
be empathetic to other people's lived
experiences
other people's points of view you know
all that kind of stuff
yes and i actually don't think it's that
hard well it's not hard in this sense so
imagine that you can
um now let's let's just let's make life
simple for a minute let's assume
that you can do a kind of partial
ordering over ideas
or clusterings of behavior it doesn't
even matter
what i mean here so long as there's some
way that this is a cluster this is a
cluster there's some edge between them
right and there's kind of
they don't quite touch even or maybe
they come very close if you can
imagine that conceptually then the way
you get from here to here is not by
going from here to here the way you get
from here to here is you find the edge
and you move slowly together right and i
think that machines are actually very
good at that sort of thing once we can
kind of define the problem either in
terms of behavior or ideas or words or
whatever
so it's easy in the sense that if you
already have the network
and you know the relationships you know
the edges and sort of the strings on
them and
you kind of have some semantic meaning
for them the machine doesn't have to
you do as a designer uh then yeah i
think you can kind of move people along
and sort of expand them
but it's harder than that and the reason
it's harder than that um
or sort of coming up with the network
structure itself is hard is because i'm
gonna tell you a story that i
someone else told me and i don't i may
get some of the details a little bit
wrong but it's it's roughly
it roughly goes like this you take two
sets of people
from the same backgrounds and you want
them to solve a problem
so you separate them up which we do all
the time right now you know we're going
to break out into we're going to break
out groups you're going to go over there
and you're going to talk about this
you're going to go over there and talk
about this
and then you have them uh sort of in
this big room but far apart from one
another and you have them sort of
interact with one another
when they come back to talk about what
they learn you want to merge what
they've done together
it can be extremely hard because they
don't
they basically don't speak the same
language anymore like when you create
these problems and you dive into them
you create your own language
so the example this one person gave me
which i i found kind of interesting
because we were in the middle of that at
the time
was they're sitting over there and
they're talking about these rooms that
you can see
but you're seeing them from different
vantage points depending on which side
of the room you're on
they can see a clock very easily and so
they start referring to the room as the
one with the clock
this group over here looking at the same
room they can see the clock but
it's you know not in their line of sight
or whatever so they end up um
referring to it by some other way when
they get back together and they're
talking about things
they're referring to the same room and
they don't even realize they're
referring to the same room in fact this
group doesn't even see that there's a
clock there and this group doesn't see
whatever
the clock on the wall is the thing that
stuck with me so if you create these
different silos the problem isn't that
the ideologies disagree
it's that you're using the same words
and they mean
radically different things the hard part
is just getting them to agree
on the well maybe we'd say the axioms in
our world right but you know just get
them to agree on
some basic definitions because right now
they talk
they're talking past each other just
completely talking past each other
that's the hard part getting them to
meet
getting them to interact that may not be
that difficult getting them to see
where their language is leading them to
lead past one another that's
that's the hard part it's a really
interesting question to me it could be
on the layer of language but it feels
like there's multiple layers to this
like it could be world view it could be
i mean it all boils down to empathy
being able to put yourself
in the shoes of the other person to
learn the language to
learn like visually how they see the
world to
learn like the i mean i
experienced this now with with trolls
the the degree of humor
in that world for example i talk about
love a lot i'm very like
i'm really lucky to have this amazing
community of loving people
but whenever i encounter trolls they
always roll their eyes at
the idea of love because it's so quote
unquote cringe
yeah uh so so they commun they show love
by like derision i would say
and uh i think about
on the human level that's a whole nother
discussion that's psychology that's
sociology so on but i wonder if ai
systems
can help somehow and to bridge the gap
of what is this person's
life like encourage me to just ask that
question to put myself in their shoes
to experience the agitations the fears
the hopes they have
the to experience you know the to
even just to think about what was their
upbringing like
like having a a single-parent home
or a shitty education or all those kinds
of things
just to put myself in that mind space
it feels like that's really important
for
us to for to bring those clusters
together to find that similar language
but it's unclear how ai can help that
because it seems like ai systems need to
understand both parties
first so you know the word understand
there's doing a lot of work right
yeah so yes do you have to understand it
or do you just simply have to
note that there is something similar and
there's a point to touch right
so you know you use the word empathy and
and i like that word for a lot of
reasons i think you're right in the way
that you're using in the ways you're
describing but let's separate it from
sympathy right
so you know sympathy is feeling sort of
for someone
empathy is kind of understanding where
they're coming from and how they how
they feel right and
for most people uh those things go hand
in hand for some people some are very
good at empathy and very
very bad at sympathy some people cannot
experience well
my observation would be i'm not a
psychologist my observation would be
that some people
seem incapable of feeling sympathy
unless they feel empathy first
you can understand someone understand
where they're coming from and still
think no
i i can't support that right it doesn't
mean that the only way
i because if that if that isn't the case
then what it requires is that you
um you must the only way that you can to
understand someone means you must agree
with
everything that they do which isn't
right right
and and if the only way i can feel for
someone
is to completely understand them and
make them like me
in some way well then we're lost right
because
we're not all exactly like each other i
have to understand everything that
you've gone through it helps
clearly but they're separable ideas
right even though they get clearly
clearly tangled up in one another so
what i think a i could help you do
actually is if and you know i'm being
quite
fanciful as it were but if you if you
think of these as kind of
i understand how you interact the words
that you use the district you know the
actions you take i have some way of
doing this let's not worry about what
that is
um but i can see you as a kind of
distribution of experiences and
actions taken upon you things you've
done and so on and i can do this with
someone else
and i can find the places where there's
some kind of commonality
um a mapping as it were even if it's not
total you know the
if if i think of this as distribution
right then you know i can take the
cosine of the angle between you and if
it's you know
if it's zero you've got nothing in
common if it's one you're completely the
same person
well you know you're probably not one
you're almost certainly not zero i can
find the place where there's the overlap
then i might be able to introduce you on
that basis or connect you and that
connects you in that way and make it
easier for you to take that step
that step of empathy it's not it's not
impossible to do
although i wonder if it requires that
everyone involved is at least interested
in asking the question
so maybe the hard part is just getting
them interested in asking the question
in fact maybe if you can get them to ask
the question how are we more alike
than we are different they'll solve it
themselves maybe that's the problem that
hey i should be working on not
telling you how you're similar or
different but just getting you to decide
that it's worth while asking the
question
so that feels like an economist's answer
actually
well people okay first of all people
like you and i would disagree so
let me disagree slightly which is i
think everything you said is brilliant
but i i tend to
believe philosophically speaking that
people are
interested underneath it all and i i
would say that ai
the the possibility that an ai system
would show the commonality
is incredible that's a really good
starting point i would say if you sh
if on social media i could discover the
common things
deep or shallow between me and a person
who
there's tension with i think that my
basic human nature would take over from
there and
i think enjoy that commonality and
like there's something sticky about that
that my mind will linger on
and that person in my mind will become
like warmer and warmer and like i'll
i'll start to give feel more and more
compassion towards them i i think for
majority of the population that's
true but that might be that's a
hypothesis yeah i mean it's an empirical
question right you don't have to figure
it out
i mean i want to believe you're right
and so i'm going to say that i think
you're right
of course some people come to those
things for the
purpose of trolling right and it doesn't
matter they're playing a different game
yeah but i don't know i you know my
experience is it requires
two things it requires in fact maybe
this is really at the end what you're
saying and i and i do agree with this
for sure
so you it's
hard to hold on to that kind of anger
or to hold on to just a desire to
humiliate someone for that long it's
just difficult to do it takes
it takes a a toll on you but more
importantly we know this
both from people having done studies on
it but also from our own experiences
that it is much easier to be dismissive
of a person if they're not in front of
you if they're not real
right so much of the history of the
world is about making people
other right so if you're on social media
if you're on the web if you're doing
whatever in the internet
being forced to deal with someone as a
person some
equivalent to being in the same room
makes a huge difference because in your
one you're forced to deal with their
humanity because it's in front of you
the other is of course that uh
you know they might punch you in the
face if you go too far so you know both
of those things kind of work together i
think to the
to the right so i think bringing people
together
is really a kind of substitute for
forcing them to see the humanity in
another person
and to not be able to treat them as bits
it's hard to troll someone when you're
looking them in the eye
this is very difficult to do agreed
you